les réfugiés d'indochine
plusieurs centaines d'entre eux sont
accueillis ce soir à paris la chute de
skylab ce sera demain dernière hypothèse
il tomberait dans l'océan indien
sept morts 12 blessés dans l'incendié du
boulevard d'ornano à paris c'est l'acte
d'un déséquilibré
là messieurs bonsoir le drame de l'ado
chine ce soir encore à la face du monde
avec l'arrivée du premier contingent de
réfugiés cambodgiens à paris on commence
à toucher du doigt ce qu'a été le
cauchemar de ces hommes de ces femmes et
des enfants sur lesquels nous n'avions
pu braquer nos caméras jusqu alors que
propose de vous en par ailleurs
l'instant car grâce à la conjugaison des
moyens techniques et de la prouesse de
nos différentes équipes de journalistes
et techniciens nous pourrons voir à la
fois le départ de ces réfugiés et je
l'espère leur arrivée en france il ya
quelques minutes
mais d'abord donc le sort de l'autre
population de réfugiés que nous avons si
j'ose dire davantage prise en charge
moralement car de nos journalistes les
ont suivis depuis plusieurs semaines en
permanence en mer de chine
je parle là des réfugiés vietnamiens
c'est à dire pour simplifier ceux qui
veulent quitter leur pays et qui se
cognent tels des papillons refus de la
malaisie et dans une moindre mesure de
hong kong et de l'indonésie
le bateau sur lequel se trouvaient nos
deux journalistes jacques à bouchard et
patrick dutertre vient d'achever
provisoirement sa mission l'île de
lumière est arrivé hier à singapour
pour l'ide de lumière ce bateau hôpital
à bord duquel pendant plusieurs semaines
au large de culo bidons des médecins
français ont essayé de soulager un peu
la misère de ces réfugiés vietnamiens
mais abords de l'île de lumière pour 837
personnes
c'était la fin d'un immense calvaire ils
ont été recueillies et rend sur la mer
de chine entre poule aux bidons et
singapour ballotté par les flots sur des
embarcations de fortune
des hommes des femmes des enfants qui
avaient décidé de fuir le nouveau
vietnam
exténué par la fatigue brûlé par le
soleil
ils sont prostrés revenant lentement à
la ville sur la mer de chine des
dizaines d'embarcations avec des
centaines de fuyards n'ont pas eu la
chance de ceux qui se retrouvent
aujourd'hui sur l'île de lumière
repousser des quotes-parts des états qui
ne veulent pas les accueillir
attaqués pillés violés par des pirates
voilà ce qui les attend nos envoyés
spéciaux à bord de l'île de lumière
jacquat bouchard et patrice du tertre
vous présenteront dans quelques jours ce
qu'ils ont vu et filmer un reportage
plus qu'un reportage
un témoignage bouleversant
une précision tous les passagers de
lille le milieu lumière donc tous sans
exception seront prises en charge par la
france ils recevront un visa ils sont
donc huit cent cinquante ans tout
deuxième équipe envoyée par antenne 2
dans cette région du monde une région
tuméfié françois corner et jean paul ii
a tremblé il s'était en thaïlande à la
frontière cambodgienne
il s'agit là d'un autre drame dont nous
vous parlions - faute d'image le drame
de ces familles qui veulent franchir la
frontière mais qui sont refoulés par les
thaïlandais chez eux
pire bangkok mines parfois les routes
pour isoler complètement ses malheurs en
corner vous revenez il ya deux heures à
peine de bangkok
oui nous allons vous présenter un
document qui était tourné la nuit
dernière dans un camp de réfugiés avant
le rapatriement de ces réfugiés pour la
france c'était la nuit dernière en
thaïlande ces gens attendaient l'avion
qui devait les rapatrier un avion
affrété par le secours catholique et un
autre avion est arrivé aujourd'hui avec
environ 300 réfugiés à bord on en attend
5000 environ avant quelques semaines
en france nous allons donc vous
présenter ces quelques images que nous
avons essayé de tourner rapidement la
nuit dernière dans ce camp de réfugiés
qui se trouvait dans la banlieue de
bangkok
et si ce film n'est pas prêt puisque
nous venons de le développer
je propose que nous leur posons un peu
dans le courant du journée on peut
parler ensemble quand même qu est ce que
vous avez ressenti en arrivant donc dans
ce camp de réfugiés et j'ai ressenti
d'abord une très grosse angoisse de la
part des gens qui se trouvaient dans ces
camps de réfugiés et il y a certaines
personnes qui vont être sauvés et bien
sûr par les français par les américains
et d'autres missions qui sont sur place
notamment
allemand de et je pense que le gros
problème c'est que certains resteront en
thaïlande ne seront pas sauvés alors on
ne sait pas ce que ces gens vont devenir
où ils seront refoulés comme quarante
mille autres qui ont été refoulés
dernièrement ou alors la thaïlande en
adoptera quelques-uns mais ce n'est pas
certain du tout il faut dire qu'ils sont
presque pris au piège puisque nous avons
dit qu'effectivement elle et thaïlandais
avaient miné les routes d'accès de du
cambodge et nous avions d'ailleurs les
images on y rapportait l'instrument cité
la nuit dernière donc en thaïlande 400
femmes hommes et enfants vont quitter ce
camp de réfugiés cambodgiens pour la
france sera pas payée par le secours
catholique français pour eux c'est la
fin du cauchemar dans leur bep presse
ils ont eu si l'on peut prononcer le mot
de la chance celle de ne pas avoir été
refoulés au cambodge après cette entrée
en territoire thaïlandais celle de ne
pas avoir été coincé comme trente mille
autres comme nous le disions doute leur
dans les champs de mines à la frontière
celle de ne pas être tombé sous les
balles des soldats thaïlandais ou
massacrés par l'armée cambodgienne en
essayant de retourner dans leur pays
pendant des jours des semaines parfois
des mois ces réfugiés ont été privés de
nourriture de médicaments
ils ont subi les moussons avant d'être
récupéré par les organisations
humanitaires et rapatriés sur bangkok
l'un de ces rescapés médecins cnom
prennent des témoignages parmi les gens
qui ont été refoulés à ce moment là il
ya beaucoup de gens qui osent qui
mouraient qui sont morts par la famine
on manque de nourriture pendant que des
leçons aussi
et aussi il ya aussi pas
il ya des morts par intoxication par
empoisonnement dans l'eau il a mis les
et des poisons d'un bandeau et puis ces
gens là boucle
la mise à l'eau et en mourir en
attendant le départ voire conférence de
genève la thaïlande avait promis de ne
plus refouler de réfugiés cambodgiens
le gouvernement thaïlandais va de
méditation en ce sens à olivier stirn le
secrétaire d'état français aux affaires
étrangères
actuellement sur place pour s'occuper de
ce problème du rapatriement de ces
réfugiés vers la france ce que le
premier ministre thaïlandais avait
promis et qui est tenu
c'est qu'il n'y aurait pas en effet de
refoulement de réfugiés arrivant par la
mer de chine ou arrivant par divers
moyens de l'extérieur ça c'est cela se
passe par contre il a bloqué sa
frontière
c'est à dire que il ya une frontière
commune comme vous le savez entre le
cambodge et la thaïlande sénat est
bloqué il empêche les cambodgiens qui
souhaiteraient venir les qr 2 de venir
en aide
concrètement dans quel délai pensez vous
pouvoir évacuer les réfugiés cambodgiens
vers la france il y en a qui vont partir
il y en a déjà qui sont partis de
malaisie
dans les prochaines semaines et les 5000
que le gouvernement a pris en supplément
seront en france vous partez maintenant
sur un oeil pour rencontrer le premier
ministre nouri et damien qu'espéraient
les obtenir
je vais expliquer la politique de la
france
je vais mettre les vietnamiens devant
leurs responsabilités
le leur dire très clairement et puis je
les écoute et je vais voir ce qu'ils
vont proposer à genève je vais voir
quelles sont leurs intentions réfugiés
cambodgiens ou vietnamiens seront donc
acheminés vers la france au cours des
prochaines semaines deux contingents
embarqué ce matin bangkok pour paris un
prochain avion frété par le secours
catholique français quittera paris
dimanche prochain pour en rapatrier 400
ce matin à bord un homme ému et six
têtes à ce premier gros rapatriement il
s'appelle robert était c'est le chef des
missions qu'on en dise arabe le long de
la frontière les avoir revu dans un camp
voix c'est se demandant s'ils souhaitent
être accueillis et les avoir vus enfin
hier soir avec presque avec le sourire
aux lèvres
et encore ce matin nous avons vraiment
conscience d'avoir sauvé deux vies
humaines voyez france par l'illusion que
la frontière est bloquée elle est
bloquée alors pour ceux qui ont réussi à
la franchir c'est le bonheur c'est oui
bien sûr mobilité mais pour les autres
c'est peut-être la mort mais bien sûr
parce que la nourriture parvenir à nihat
nos peines ni à l'air bien sûr ils ont
essayé de de retourner en territoire
cambodgien mais certains ont été
massacrés par les cambodgiens bien sûr
pour se venger et ils le font tirer
dessus aussi par les soldats thaïlandais
ils sont coincés donc privés de
nourriture comme on le disait tout à
l'heure de médicaments dans les champs
de mines
mais ces champs de mines n'ont pas été
mis à planter là pour bloquer les
réfugiés cc des champs de mines qui
existait à la frontière cambodgienne et
thaïlandaise
mais bien sûr tout le monde est inquiet
pour savoir ce qui va se passer dans ses
champs de mines et pour l'instant la
thaïlande interdit au secours de se
rendre sur place aux journalistes aussi
du reste puisque nous avons été bloqués
nous n'avons pas pu y aller hier pour
faire comprendre un petit peu toutes ces
conditions d'improvisation de ce journal
sachez que les différents avions
viennent tout juste d'arriver il a fallu
que nos équipes techniques le
laboratoire télécinéma la régie
les journalistes et d'ailleurs du son on
fasse le maximum mettre les bouchées
doubles pour que vous voyez les
documents qui viennent donc d'arriver il
ya quelques instants
en même temps que françois conte et kiev
lui n'a pas dormi depuis plusieurs
heures
et depuis plusieurs jours m donc nous
avons vu les conditions de départ de ces
réfugiés cambodgiens je vous propose
maintenant de rejoindre l'aéroport de
roissy pour les retrouver en principe à
leur arrivée il ya donc très peu de
temps roissy où d'ailleurs la navette
des avions s'est intensifiée trois
appareils en moins de trois heures en
provenance d'inde de chine allons
rejoindre pierre fock qui a rencontré
quelques-uns de ces réfugiés qui
viennent tout juste d'arriver à roissy
c'est à 17h30 que le boeing 747 spécial
d'air france affrété par le secours
catholique est arrivé à son bord quatre
cent quatre réfugiés cambodgiens venant
de bangkok
un peu plus tard à 18h10 un autre
appareil affrété lui par la ville de
paris
arrivés de kuala lumpur avec 277
réfugiés vietnamiens a dit que voilà la
presse
initié en bateau en attendant après il
faut que l'évacuation n'importe où
l'épave
il faut quitter city la bise donc il
devait quitter n'importe où et puis
après si si les gens ne quittait pas
pour les âmes à 9h à 20h30 dans quelques
instants
j'en attends 157 nouveaux réfugiés
transporté par un avion affrété par
l'association solidarité internationale
présidée par françois mitterrand
voilà si vous voulez faire un geste
sachez que france terre d'asile qui est
située à 29
notamment dans le xvème à paris a besoin
de couvertures et d'autres produits de
première nécessité elle a besoin aussi
d'établissement à caractère social
disposant de 30 à 120 places libre
immédiatement et jusqu'à noël pour y
accueillir des réfugiés du sud est
asiatique donc france car dassier voilà
deuxième gros dossier de la journée
maintenant skylab la date fatidique se
rapproche les frissons gagne les uns les
autres partagé entre le scepticisme peu
ironique et la franche craintes mais
c'est sûr c'est pour demain très
exactement entre 11 heures du matin et
00h45
la nasa est optimiste pense que la chute
du satellite devrait intervenir au
dessus de 600 indiens
mais d'autres experts sont plus inquiets
ans parus pour la france
cet astronaute américain pouvait-il
imaginer qu'il reverrait un jour son
laboratoire de l'espace faire le grand
retour de skylab est prévue pour demain
les 78 tonnes de métal exploseront sans
doute dans l'atmosphère entre 11 heures
du matin et minuit
skylab est actuellement incendie 190 km
du sol ils tombent chaque jour de 14 km
sa chute s'accélère lorsque la densité
de l'air deviendra trop fort il se
fragmentera en mille morceaux dont les
plus lourds atteindront le sol arrosant
une région 200 km de long des cendres
seront répandues sur un ou deux milliers
de kilomètres l'incertitude de leur de
rentrée est tel que de nombreuses
régions sont visés l'océan indien
d'abord l'australie puis les états unis
ensuite mais si skylab décidé d'abréger
sa fin paris est sur la trajectoire
skylab passera la verticale de la
capitale à 9h13 11h15 et 12h46
la population américaine a pris le parti
de rire de la situation
cible sur les t-shirts sur le toit des
maisons trousse de survie ou potion
magique
tout était prévu mais cet humour à toute
chance d'échapper aux australiens ou aux
français car même si les probabilités
sont infimes
il n'est pas absolument impossible que
l'un des morceaux de plus d'une tonne
tombe sur une maison à plus de 500
kilomètres à l'heure et en rase mottes
les autorités américaines ont beau
déclarer qu elles rembourseront tous les
dégâts les assurances ont déjà été
proposées aux plus crédules d'autres
promettent 10000 dollars de récompense a
requis leur rapporterait 1 à bout de
l'engin spatial ainsi la journée de
demain risque de se terminer en une
gigantesque course au trésor oui voyez
vous il renie du sang il ya dix ans très
exactement le 20 juillet 1969 deux
hommes mettaient sur pied et mettez le
pied pour la première fois au monde sur
la lune sur le bord sud ouest de la mer
de la tranquillité le premier d'entre
eux s'appelle neil armstrong il est avec
nous ce soir car l'équipe darmangeat
mots et des dossiers de l'écran l'ont
invité pour un dossier pas comme les
autres alors il pourra répondre à vos
questions mais je lui pose tout de suite
celle ci cette incapacité de la nasa à
récupérer ce qu'elles lancent
aujourd'hui est ce qu'elle ne vous
paraît pas être une régression de la
technique dix ans après
ilham tombée est-ce que vous m'avez
entendu d'abord alain jérôme est ce que
vous pensez que votre invité nous
entendu là je me le demande
alors je lui repose la question pour
l'instant je l'entends alors là je pense
qu'il va pouvoir nous entendre
est ce que vous croyez pas quand même
que dix ans après cette prouesse
exceptionnelle qui était l'arrivée d'un
homme sur la lune
il n'y a pas une petite ironie du sort à
avoir la nasa à voir tant de difficultés
à essayer de récupérer la 26e objets
perdus dans le ciel essayez-vous là il
vous allez traduire la question est
notre invité la question de patrick
poivre d'arvor est de savoir si il n'y a
pas un problème du côté de la nasa ne
qui ne n'arrive pas à récupérer ce
skylab qu'elle avait lancée et se
compensent neil amstrong bien c'est au
petit peu triste évidemment que je sais
ça se passe en ce moment c'est triste
d'ailleurs deux dossistes et à la mort
de skylab
parce que là bas c'était une expérience
une grande expérience et une grande
noblesse dans cette opération
c'était une grande chose
et puis il faut dire aussi que cette
chose qui préoccupe énormément de gens
et on le comprend on comprend bien
les dernières informations que l'on a de
la nasa
c'est qu'il est très probable que ça se
passera à 6 heures demain
6h02 et dans l'atlantique sud
par conséquent personne ne sera en péril
leur a pas de pas de danger particulier
pour qui que ce soit et ça peut
évidemment varier d'une orbite ou de
bien sûr bien à neil amstrong jour merci
parce que vous nous avez apporté une
information tout à fait exlusif laurent
broomhead ne l'avait pas tout est là
dans son commentaire
donc apparemment selon vous la retombée
dans l'atmosphère et pour 18h02 au
dessus de l'atlantique donc on ne risque
rien en tout cas on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure pour parler de choses plus gaies
pourparlers en tout cas de votre
expérience à vous il ya dix ans donc au
cours des dossiers de l'écran vers 20h35
et puis nous restons quand même aux
états unis avec la prolongation du
suspense de camp david jimmy carter
consulte toujours l'un de ses
conseillers le secrétaire adjoint à
l'énergie a démissionné et rien ne sort
de washington alors que des décisions
très importantes restent à prendre dont
trouvant sur place édouard leur journée
de mardi
et cela dure maintenant depuis une
semaine pour te de cordes évident de se
refermer pour ce que les états unis
peuvent planter politique économique ou
simplement payer personne ne s'en occupe
demain le président carter on sera même
une délégation de chefs religieux
tout cela pour dire et les américains
commencent sérieusement y penser
le président carter le travail pas
seulement sur ce fameux plan sur
l'énergie premier maintenant depuis
quatre mois qui cherche par la même
occasion ce qui serait aujourd'hui
encore sceptiques soutenir aux
prochaines élections est vrai que pour
cet homme de plus en plus seul retranché
dans sa résidence quand des villes
régions dangereuses mans
rudy décision d'autant plus importante
pour les occidentaux que le dialogue
entre l'opep et la communauté européenne
est pour l'instant suspendu voilà en
tout cas qui tempère un petit peu
l'optimisme des européens à soulager et
par la décision des saoudiens
d'augmenter la production de leur
pétrole et par celle de virac de
s'engager à aider la france en cas de
besoin pierre materi oui vous savez il
faut jamais être trop optimiste quand on
fait de l'alpinisme mais les pays
occidentaux sont en ce moment un peu
dans la situation d'un alpiniste qui
cherchent une prise pour sa main gauche
parce qu'il sait bien que dans l'autre
main l'autre main est agrippé sur un
rocher qui n'est pas très solide qu'en
matière d'énergie le rocher le plus
fragile en ce moment c'est l'iran
incontestablement il manque une partie
de la production iranienne sur le marché
d'où la satisfaction immédiatement
annoncé par jimmy carter lorsque les
saoudiens eux pour compenser ont
confirmé qu'ils allaient augmenter leur
production d'un million de barils par
jour ce million de barils par jour c'est
une prise qui s'affermit et la france
vient de trouver une deuxième prise pour
ce fait revenir à bagdad alors voyez
comme un homme voyez une relation
pétrolières avec l'irak l'année dernière
nous lui avons acheté 20 millions de
tonnes sur un total de 115 millions de
tonnes d'importations
vous savez que sont maintenant constante
nous efforçons de les plafonner ses
importations
cette année en février premier geste de
bonne volonté des irakiens 5 millions de
tonnes de plus et depuis hier nous avons
donc quelque chose encore en plus c'est
une promesse cette promesse je cite
c'est la continuité et la sécurité dans
l'approvisionnement pétrolier promesse
que raymond barre a ramené de bagdad
cela veut dire que la france pourrait
éventuellement s'il en a besoin
acheté jusqu'à trente millions de tonnes
et peut être même plus aux irakiens en
1980 l'année prochaine alors est ce que
c'est la fin de la pénurie pétrolière
pour la france alors que le marché
mondial est en ce moment toujours tendu
est toujours dangereux ce serait
peut-être exagéré enfin une sécurité
c'est toujours bon à prendre il faut
toujours garder un oeil sur les prix
exactement j'ai pris 20 je ne crée pas
un deuxième petit perdons sur les prix
il faut tout de même savoir que si
l'approvisionnement irakien devient sûr
et qu'il reste continue et c'est une
bonne chose
seulement il faut savoir aussi que le
pétrole irakien et entre 20 et 22
dollars le baril alors si c'est pour
remplacer le manque à produire des
iraniens qui sont à peu près dans les
mêmes prix c'est une excellente chose
mais bien entendu ce sera une mauvaise
opération financière de remplacer par la
du pétrole saoudien non je crois qu'on
peut faire confiance aux compagnies
pétrolières pour ne pas acheter du
pétrole à vannes 2 si on peut le voir
18 dollars le baril qui compte en fait
ce n'est pas le chiffre c'est le mot
sécurité les approvisionnements et cette
sécurité nous en avons vraiment très
besoin et puis n'oublions pas que en
toile de fond de ce problème énergétique
reste en suspens la question du
règlement de la paix au proche orient
aujourd'hui je men are and begin le
premier ministre israël est arrivé en
fin de matinée à alexandrie pour une
visite de trois jours en egypte les
conversations officielles avec anouar el
sadate ce devrait commencer en ce moment
même l'entourage de menahem begin parle
surtout d'une visite de bon voisinage
etc vous le voyez sur ces images de
donner un caractère trop officiel en
trop protocolaire à ce voyage
dernière nouvelle maintenant en
provenance de l'étranger elles nous
viennent du luxembourg on a assisté au
début des grandes manoeuvres en plus de
la conquête de la présidence du nouveau
parlement européen
l'attribution de ce poste sera chose
faite la semaine prochaine mais j'ai là
quelques éléments très intéressants
d'appréciation d'abord le fait que
simone vesle et ait été choisie comme
candidate du groupe libéral aux dépens
de gaston thorn 20 voix pour la
française 16 pour le luxembourgeois
du côté des chrétiens démocrates cda
c'est monsieur klebs un allemand qui a
été élu à la présidence du groupe mais
on ne sait pas qui sera leur candidat à
la présidence de l'ensemble de
l'assemblée autre monsieur colombo et
puis chez les démocrates européens de
progrès c'est le rpr christian de la
malène qui a été élu président en europe
enfin l'iran dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure suite des remous au sein du
pouvoir hier soir je n'en sais que le
général rémi un dur le chef de la police
militaire avait été destitué par le
ministre de la défense il avait refusé
deux parties avaient aujourd'hui il a
été confirmé dans ses fonctions par
l'ayatollah khomeiny paris maintenant
justice dans une heure ou deux maximum
l'arrêt de la cour de sûreté de l'état
au terme du procès des 21 autonomistes
corses les pédos harry viennent de
s'achever sur le même thème qu'importe
les fait l'intéressant c'est le problème
corse jean louis lahaye scène qui m'a
téléphoné tout à l'heure et sur place
ils nous appellent dès le jugement est
rendu et puis t-mobile christian part
dans chrysler simca est mort vive talbot
et puis 15 heures cet après midi
des plus grandes firmes automobiles en
été changées nous effleure simca se
parle maintenant d'un nom que les
nostalgiques des vieilles voitures
connaissent bien talbot talbot cette
marque prestigieuse de l'avant guerre et
de l'immédiate après guerre
grâce aux majors lago que l'on voit ici
c'est à partir de 1935 que la marque
talbot commence à devenir célèbre à
l'époque talbot fait partie du groupe
brutt sunbeam et talbot lago groupe que
simca rachète en 1958 le point culminant
de l'histoire talbot 1950 avec la
victoire de la fameuse lago record aux
24 heures du mans avec au volant louis
rosiers entre 1935 et 1950 les talbot
lago glanant compétition d'innombrables
succès grand prix de l'acf à lyon grand
prix de belgique grand prix des pays-bas
et bien d'autres encore
les pilotes qui se succèdent au volant
pour nom louis rosiers bien sûr mais
aussi louis chiron et philippe etancelin
fifi pour les connaisseurs parallèlement
les voitures de série se hisse au niveau
des meilleurs au tout début en 1902 le
comte anglais talbot shrewsbury
s'associe à l'industriel français
adolphe clément après une carrière
mouvementée après avoir changé de mains
plusieurs reprises
talbot disparaît tout à fait au moment
du rachat de simca par chrysler à la fin
de l'année dernière peugeot prend le
contrôle de chrysler europe dans les
dossiers une marque talbot aujourd'hui
dépoussiérer remise au goût du jour bien
avec nous donc l'un des responsables de
cette société talbot maintenant de
l'ancienne société chrysler simca
monsieur perrin pelletier qui est
derrière moi j'ai demandé qu'on me fasse
pour qu'on le voit alors monsieur
pelletier première question est ce que
ça veut dire
le retour en france on oublie carrément
le caractère américain jusqu alors de
chrysler simca est ce que c'est la
situation
et bien maintenant comme vous le savez
sim car chrysler est abandonné au profit
de talbot et nous ne pouvions pas gardé
le nom de chrysler qui est celui d'un
constructeur américain nous avons donc
choisi un nom de talbot car nous pensons
qu'il y à beaucoup plus de gens que vous
ne le pense peut-être à aimer la voiture
est ce que ce n'est pas vrai comme image
de marque talbot mais non parce que
justement ce que nous cherchons avec
talbot ce n'est pas de construire des
voitures comme celles que vous avez à
mes côtés mais bien un esprit l'esprit
de l'automobile séduisante performante
agréable à conduire et qui j'en suis sûr
trouvera beaucoup d'adeptes en france
est-ce que ça va se traduire sur le vos
produits que vous vendez à l'heure
actuelle parce qu'il ya quand même
il n'ya pas de commune mesure entre les
anciennes talbot les produits de
consommation courants dès maintenant et
bien vous savez avec l'horizon qui est
de l'autre côté je pense que nous avons
un produit agréable à conduire mais
néanmoins qui répondent aux contraintes
de notre époque c'est à dire qui est
économe en énergie et le pensons qu'il
est possible à la fois de mélanger ces
deux côtés nous naturellement nous
donneront à nos concessionnaires une
gamme plus complète et il y aura d'ici
deux ans un modèle haut de gamme qui
viendra compléter leur gamme et
renforcer notre image de marque vous
appartenait au groupe peugeot psa
citroën vous en êtes vous même issue
super pelletier vous êtes le petit
dernier et crysler vous êtes un peu
souffreteux par rapport à la bonne santé
de vos partenaires de groupe
est-ce que talbot va vous donner des
ailes bien côté les derniers peut-être
de la famille mais pas les petits
derniers parce que nous avons une
situation qui est tout à fait comparable
et un poids comparable à celui de
peugeot et de citroën c'est à dire que
nous faisons 6% du marché européen et
nous avons même une branche poids lourd
alors la situation
effectivement et retenu tout à fait
normal et nous espérons bien l'année
prochaine et dès cette année augmenter
nos ventes
eh bien merci monsieur perrin beatty
n'dori donc le baptême de
la talbot une ensemble donc la gamme
chrysler simca s'appellera donc la gamme
talbot des angles dockers le mouvement
lancé par la cgt a été suivie à 100%
pour la deuxième journée consécutive par
les 17000 dockers elle s'achève
aujourd'hui à paris boulevard ornano
dans le xviiie arrondissement un
incendie cette nuit d'un hôtel dont les
locataires étaient pour la plupart des
travailleurs immigrés sept morts et 12
blessés c'est l'indication vie les plus
meurtriers il est d'origine criminelle
son auteur avait été récemment soignée
dans un hôpital psychiatrique
j'ai voulu immolé par le feu
c'est l'aveu fait par michel guérin 36
ans malade mental soigner hier encore à
l'hôpital de 8,8 et qui a aussi expliqué
aux enquêteurs sa pitoyable histoire
d'hommes seuls j'ai volé un bidon
d'essence dans une voiture je n'ai
verser dans la montée de l'immeuble
j'ai voulu me jeter dans le brasier mais
l'explosion a été si forte que j'ai été
pris de panique
conséquence tous blessés dont deux
graves mais surtout sept morts dont
trois personnes qui se sont écrasés sur
le sol de cette cour en sautant dans le
vide pour échapper aux flammes
je sais que j'ai entendu crier le voisin
et puis quand on s'est réveillé on
j'étais ouvert la porte et qu'il
souhaitait prendre fumée
ok leurs miles davis vers les 3 heures
hé hé
vous êtes partis précipitamment je vous
voilà en chemise de nuit et non
rester puisque tout de suite les
colonies les ponts sont venues
arraisonner vient fermer les portes les
fenêtres équité
monter l'exemple
les chercher j'ai entendu comme une
bourrasque formidable accompagné d'un
souffle extraordinaire comme si un avion
à réaction passait juste au-dessus la
maison alors là j'ai ouvert une fenêtre
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des flammes au
milieu de la maison je suis passé de
l'autre côté pour ce qui est arrivé
exactement et je me suis aperçu de cet
extraordinaire
on aurait dit une lampe formidable
formidable lampe de poche d'eau plombier
n'est ce pas belga zen ou n'ont pas
souhaité non pas sauté il y avait un
geste fort moins trois mètres à partir
de là près de mon voisin tout s'est
passé très vite
attisées par l'appel d'air de la cage
d'escalier et les portes ouvertes des
quinze logements les flammes atteignent
le 7e étage de cet automne
ce bateau braconniers le sien lasserait
sud africain est financé par le japon la
norvège et le liechtenstein
on estime que les grands mammifères
marins et environ deux millions cinq
cent mille en 1930 ne sont plus que six
cent cinquante mille aux différents
sites à la liste de ses forces de
traquer les chasseurs selon lieux de
pêche les états concernés par
l'industrie la baleine tentent de
limiter leurs appels en france par
exemple le bata annuelle est passée de
38 ans 1975 à 4500 cette année certains
pays comme les usa l'australie souhaite
que des mesures nous pousser vers
surprise voire même la cam ils sont plus
simples ne cherche à convaincre les
irréductibles puis à l'ascèse japon il
traite 80 à 90% des baleines tuées
chaque année ce sera la plus grande
tâche des pays membres de la commission
baleinière internationale les sports
maintenant aujourd'hui c'était la 13e
étape du tour de france disputée entre
mecs c'est le sommet du ballon d'alsace
nous tous qui n'a pas apporté les
changements l'on espérait histoire de
voir l'arrivée du français vraiment
génial
pierre hémon vinyan a critiqué bernard
hinault qui l'emporté aujourd'hui au
sommet du ballon d'alsace au terme de
l'étape n'a pas apporté de grands
changements mais qui était menée bon
train
la mire opération étant réalisées en
ligne homme qui passe de la 11ème
semaine passée parce qu'en général la
plus mauvaise part une culture qui a
tout vu ses efforts d'hier qui a dû
concéder une minute dix pour le reste
comme on pouvait le penser
on a vu ce que tu appelles ton jaune
collé à la route de bernard hinault en
verre comme il sait si bien le faire
pendant toute la montée du ballon
d'alsace demeurant qui n'était pas assez
dure pour faire de grosses différences
dans les derniers mètres seulement il
nous arrivait à décrocher un mec pour
les 36 secondes ce qui fait que le
breton ne fut que plus de 1000 29
secondes de retard
mais avant les traits 15 km contre la
montre de jeudi
mais surtout les états palpable est
immense et la vie qu'il ne connaît pas
les détails pour la victoire finale
or les quatre coupes européennes non il
ravi de septembre en irlande du nord
jouer contre l'équipe du fc prix que
nous et pour le climat la coupe des
coupes en coupe d'europe des clubs
champions maintenant strasbourg jouera
pour lui car c'est le premier marché
français devraient s'imposer match plus
difficile une heure avant je savais
tiennent dans la coupe de l'uefa qui
jouera à l'autre en pologne enfin monaco
ira en urss et sera opposé au champion
ce n'est plus pour l'instant donné la
météo aujourd'hui furent pratiquement
sans doute demain le temps sera
ensoleillé uniquement de les voir sur la
moitié nord-est de l'aquitaine et le
placent au journal se termine maintenant
de l'avoir suivi en notre compagnie
votre prochain rendez vous avec la
formation
je sais par terre
quoi